and not nuclear power to destroy the
human race several times over
I need to show you a video that is
blowing my mind you have the ocean just
sitting there being nice and calm and
then this pops out
boom it doesn't just pop out it pops out
for a second it looks like it's just
about to fall back down and then
[Music]
this is a rocket yes a full-blown rocket
that is headed for space
oh and I know this kind of looks small
it's not small and where is this rocket
being launched from are there underwater
bases yes they're called submarines
once it gets to the surface it flies a
thousand kilometers above Earth
literally into space it starts looking
at the stars to navigate and eventually
falls back down to Earth traveling up to
like 12 000 kilometers to hit whatever
target the people who launched it wanted
it to
like what have we created with such
destructive power it threatened the
world a deadly game of stone an
undeniable strategic deterrent nuclear
warheads that can wipe out countries
submarines are cool I just gotta say it
there are these massive floating nuclear
weapons that could be anywhere at any
time that we use for psychological
warfare and actual Warfare and spying on
people and because of this these giant
vessels are actually incredibly stealthy
like you could be swimming in the ocean
one day minding your own business and
right below you there could literally be
this massive 48 000 ton metal machine
with a couple hundred humans aboard
equipped with nuclear warheads that
could be launched at a moment's notice
and you would have no idea because not
being seen is kind of their whole Mo
which is nuts because these are some big
boys like Russia's typhoon class
submarine if you just pluck that out of
the water and put it on land somewhere
you start to get a scale for how massive
this thing is like a floating building
yeah these guys are thick and they're
cruising around our oceans 250 meters
below the surface oh and something we're
going to talk about later they literally
have nuclear power plants on board
giving them basically unlimited energy
to make fresh water and oxygen which
means they it could be down here in the
depths of the ocean for decades that is
if there weren't humans aboard that
needed to come up to eat food navies
around the world who have submarines do
everything in their power to ensure that
these Subs are quiet and invisible even
magnet resistant all in the name of
being undetectable and they're always
out there right now in this very moment
there are tons of these things there are
humans on these multi-story buildings
that are floating around our oceans with
giant weapons in them this is not normal
how did we get here why were these
things invented there's a lot to
understand about submarines there's a
lot of angles we have been researching
for months and today we are going to
show you how we got here what submarines
can do and most importantly why one
submarine has enough nuclear weapons to
essentially end life on the planet as we
know it's just one submarine an increase
in submarine activity Russian re-arming
their Fleet Chinese submarines Iranian
submarines they will preserve peace for
many years to come
boy today's topic is it's so juicy and
there is so much to get through
um Nick our studio manager is building
something for today's topic I want to
show you but actually first I want to
thank the people who made this possible
so thank you better help I've become a
massive proponent of therapy I wasn't my
whole life it's only a couple years now
that I've been in therapy and it has
truly changed my life I am not saying
that because better help is sponsoring
today's video I'm not saying that as an
exaggeration I'm saying that truly
literally therapy is a life-changing
thing regardless of if you have a
clinical mental health issue like
depression or anxiety or like me you
don't have something clinical but you're
just a human who lives in this world and
has relationships and fears and stresses
therapy can truly give you tools to
approach your life in a very different
way the big problem here is that finding
a therapist can be really difficult it's
often a matter of calling and going to
waiting rooms and talking to insurance
better help changes the game on this
they're an online platform where you can
go on answer a few questions and then
based on your preferences better help
matches you with someone in their
massive network of over 25 000
therapists oh and if you don't want to
talk face to face with your therapist
via like a video call you can do text or
a chat or a phone call you get to make
that decision based on what you need and
what your preferences are if the
therapist isn't a good fit for you you
can easily change and it doesn't cost
you anything I think a lot of people
don't get therapy because it's
incredibly arduous and there's a lot of
friction in finding a therapist and
scheduling better help solve this and
makes therapy more accessible and
affordable and again I'm a giant
proponent of that there's a link in my
description it's betterhelp.com Johnny
Harris clicking that link helps support
this channel because it also gets you 10
off your first month of better help so
you can try it out at a discount and see
if it's a good fit for you thank you
better help for supporting this video
let's go check in on Nick he's building
something super cool okay Nick Nick what
are you up to oh yeah it's coming
together look at this model oh my God
that's the ssbn Andrew Jackson Lafayette
class as you can see all the pieces are
out everywhere and these are the people
look at the people oh my God if you look
up here in the front these are the bunks
these are the Torpedoes okay we will
check in with Nick in a moment as that
model gets built let me tell you how we
got here
foreign
people have been building boats to try
to go underwater for a very long time
like look at this old art where you can
see Alexander the Great going completely
underwater in a big glass Barrel this is
like 2000 years ago 1800 years later you
have Leonardo da Vinci who was busy
literally thinking of anything that
could be invented and he sketched up his
very own version of an underwater boat
this beauty right here was basically
like a big mechanical fish oh and this
is wild he kept these sketches a secret
because he feared quote the evil nature
of men who practice assassination at the
bottom of the sea like he thought that
we might use these underwater boats for
war
whoops anyway the first known boat to
actually navigate underwater was of
course built by a Dutch dude Dutch man
they're just so good at Water 150 years
later over here in what was soon to be
the United States George Washington paid
for this sucker to be made for his army
I mean there could be a whole video
about this boat the turtle
because it kind of looked like two
turtle shells put together so cute the
guy in there is just like so cozy they
tried to use the turtle in their War for
Freedom against the British but it never
really did anything useful and then it
just sank I mean cool name but it wasn't
a super useless submarine but it paved
the way 50 years later we have the
American Civil War where the Confederate
Rebels built a sub that was powered by a
bunch of guys manually turning a crank
and on board it had a long Spar torpedo
don't be fooled though Spar torpedo was
just a fancy way of saying a bomb on a
15-foot stick and they actually used it
they snuck up on a Yankee ship
underneath it with their bomb stick in
the middle of the Civil War and blew it
up and both sides sank like the
submarine sank too like it didn't work I
mean it kind of worked but
didn't really work anyway I had to
mention all of these like early
submarines because they kind of laid the
groundwork but in the 1800s things get
really serious thanks to this guy over
here in Germany Rudolph diesel invented
an engine that changed everything this
new engine mixed pressure and air and
fossil fuels that all exploded and made
things move this changed a lot of
Industries but the Germans were like
let's put these in submarines and run
them to charge a bunch of batteries that
we can use to power the sub while we're
underwater it's a lot better than the
hand crank and indeed it was but there
was one big problem which is that this
engine needs air like it needs to be
able to pump out the exhaust that it
makes and it needs to be able to suck in
air to like make energy so you can't
actually run your engines underwater so
these German Subs as stealthy as they
were were still very limited because
they could only standard water for like
48 hours max before having to come up
and give away their position so that
they could get air for their engines
this is a problem that will soon be
solved but we just need a few Wars first
[Music]
1900s we have all these big Empires that
are looking for ways to destroy
themselves with their new industrial
technology and they're getting good at
submarines they're loading them up with
more and more batteries now they have
sonar and radar capabilities so that
they can like see underwater and they
have radios and encryption devices so
they can talk to each other while
they're underwater which is everything
when you're fighting a war the Germans
call these submarines unter sea boats or
U-boats and they use them for their new
plan of unrestricted submarine warfare
which is a sterile way of just saying we
feel comfortable sneaking up on civilian
boats and sinking them and killing the
people without notice because we've
decided we are literal villains
submarine aim and fire they're deadly
Farmers
so yeah being used for horrible means
but let's be clear this is amazing
technology like this is light years
ahead of the forefathers of submarines
like the turtle or that poorly thought
out bomb on a stick thing from the Civil
War but they still have the limitation
of air they need to come up all the time
to get air for their engines no matter
how scary and stealthy they could become
and sneaking around underwater during
these wars they still have to come up to
the surface every 48 hours to run their
engines and recharge their batteries
giving away their sneaky position and
becoming way less effective as a war
tool this would be like playing
Battleship but every few turns you have
to flip your board around to show your
opponent where you are for a sec they
kind of figured this out a little bit
when they started to use these two
little tubes that allowed them to kind
of still be underwater but to like put
the tubes up and suck down air from the
surface push out exhaust but it's kind
of rubbish like having to run your noisy
engines every 48 Hours was a huge
limitation on how useful these Subs
could be
well of course the war ends Germany
loses and surrenders and some of these
U-boats that were just sitting there
were divvied up among the winners the
U.S the UK and the USSR who discovered
that wow the Germans have some amazing
submarine tech let's use this Tech to
pimp out our own Subs leapfrogging
Decades of development and this is where
things get juicy and scary
[Music]
so now you have these two former allies
the U.S and the Soviet Union looking at
each other with skepticism they both got
their hands on this German Tech and they
both know that the other got their hands
on this German Tech and they both
secretly are like we need to get way
better than the other at
let's go this was a huge priority but it
was also weird and hush hush
Cold War this begins an era of secretive
investment into submarine technology and
this is where they level up to blow all
of our minds where submarines become the
impossibly advanced machines that we
know today
[Music]
changed everything here was that humans
had learned to Tinker with atoms
breaking them apart to make incredible
amounts of energy and they used that
energy to blow things up but also to
make electricity and crucially nuclear
energy didn't require air
so it's the 1950s and you got this guy
he's a russian-born American Navy guy
named Hyman rickover and he was like
whoa wait a second you're telling me
that you can make electricity but you
don't need air light bulbs going off on
this guy's head because he's a submarine
guy and he's like let's slap these
puppies into submarines that would solve
all of our needing to come up to the
surface every couple of hours problem
the US government's like wait sorry what
did you say Rick over and rickover's
like I said let's put the nuclear power
plant inside of the submarine we got to
get ahead of the Soviets he got a lot of
pushback for this for obvious reasons
but he dug his heels in leapfrogging all
the bosses till he got to the chief of
Navy operations and whispered in his ear
his big idea and it totally worked the
story of how this went down is insane
and rickover was insane and Visionary
and I'll leave some reading in the
sources for those who want to go down
that rabbit hole
throwing a lot of discipline here just
like breezing over this guy's story but
yes it's the 50s and the US government
set about trying to put a full-blown
nuclear reactor a power plant inside of
their Giant floating weapon and they did
somehow and it changed everything the
arrival of nuclear power has broken
those bonds you can go around the world
on a core of uranium only slightly
larger than a golf ball he may have just
as profound an effect on Naval strategy
as the airplane has had on War
let's see how Nick's doing with his
model
oh here we go look at this big boy here
she is wow
[Music]
wow
I am going to put this model on my desk
and look at it every day because it's
beautiful and it's like retro which is
kind of cool anyway uh let's get back to
the story here because the next chapter
here is really the chapter that matters
most once they got the nuclear reactor
onto these Subs everything changed I'm
going to show you why
so look at this big old submarine it's a
sturgeon-class submarine from the 60s to
U.S Navy sub and look back here we've
got the nuclear reactor it sits back
here doing its thing breaking atoms
apart which produces an enormous amount
of heat that can heat up water that
turns this massive propeller and
remember that spinning things gives you
power electricity boom you're spinning
turbines and now you have electricity
for your submarine not only does the
nuclear reactor not need air to work but
it literally creates air after all it's
surrounded by H2O so all it needs to do
is break the two h's from the O and boom
you've got oxygen for your crew to
breathe I mean this nuclear reactor was
magic move over trees we've got
submarines and they use all of this
abundant energy to get rid of salt in
the water so now the crew has like
drinking water and can take showers
while they are floating hundreds of
meters under the ocean like this is
becoming really insane the nuclear
reactor solved all the problems remember
how diesel submarines had to refuel all
the time timing that to come up to the
surface to run their engines get rid of
their exhaust and suck in the air
nuclear submarines could now run
underwater without needing to refuel for
20 years oh that is if you don't count
having to refuel the humans on board so
rickover was right nuclear reactors on
submarines changed everything they are
now way more useful you can now sneak
around the ocean and never give away
your position okay so now that we can be
underwater for basically ever let's load
these suckers up with big weapons
[Applause]
these suckers are getting huge by like
the 70s and 80s I mean here was the
German U-Boat remember the one that the
thing that like really like pushed it
all forward and here is an American Cold
War era submarine the Ohio class this
thing is massive like zoom in here those
are people here's their kitchen
here's the reactor back here doing all
of its magic and look here's where the
crew sleeps
oh and what are they sleeping next to
what are all these tubes doing here oh
these tubes kind of right where the crew
is sleeping yeah these tubes are what
make the submarine maybe the most
important weapon to have ever existed
this is where the nukes are
[Music]
well technically we don't know that this
is where the nukes are and any
Submariner will vehemently tell you that
quote we cannot confirm or deny whether
or not the missiles inside of these
silos carry nuclear weapons wink wink
this is where the nukes are so what
started as two superpowers nerding out
about German submarine Tech in the 40s
turned into an arms race that resulted
in both of them figuring out how to
power their subs with nuclear reactors
and the ability to load up these Subs
with 24 rockets that they could launch
to the edge of space at any moment
carrying multiple nuclear warheads like
having nuclear weapons on land ready to
fire is pretty cool having them on
planes is pretty powerful but you can
see both of those things when you have a
sub quietly roving around the world's
oceans with the ability to carry a bunch
of nuclear weapons and to launch them at
any point you've just achieved the most
powerful advantage in military strategy
surprise the panopticon your enemy has
no idea where you are but they know you
are somewhere in range at all times so
they have to act as if you are
everywhere a few you button presses away
from launching one of these things but
this psychological sort of mind game
only works if you are never noticed so
the next phase of this technological
evolution of submarines focuses on
silence they start coding their
submarines with rubber tiles so that the
Sonar doesn't bounce off as well they
took these giant propellers that yes are
massive bigger than you can imagine and
made them impossibly quiet and even on
the inside they started taking crazy
precautions like all the heavy gear in a
submarine is mounted on rubber pads to
dampen any vibration that could be
detected or heard the cooks even started
putting rubber on everything like
they're mixing bowls and they're mixing
spatulas are all like sound deadening
materials so that they don't send out
vibration and make noise the submarine
force is serious about silence in fact
they take pride in calling themselves
the silent service and it's kind of a
chip on their shoulder because they
don't get nearly as much recognition as
like these guys do they're just like
lurking in the depths of the ocean doing
doing like a really important defense
thing and no one knows about them
because literally that's their job is to
never be noticed
wow so you have the US and the Soviet
Union both with the ability to launch
nukes from their submarines and
ironically this whole everyone pointing
a gun at each other thing actually keeps
these great powers from ever fighting a
war with each other they were both too
afraid of how easy it would be for the
other to strike back with their stealthy
Subs ensuring the destruction of both
sides this is deterrence and it is one
of the major forces keeping great powers
from going to war with each other it's
why the U.S has an entire fleet of Subs
with no other Mission than to go into
the ocean and just disappear and just
sit there silently ready to make good on
their threat that if you attack us we
are always ready to respond
submarines are also really good for
spying
okay so we know by now that a lot of
communication in this world is made
possible because of underwater cables
it's not just the internet these cables
have existed for a very long time and
they're just sitting there at the bottom
of the ocean connecting the whole world
and they're safe because no one has
access to them no one's going to go to
the very bottom of the ocean oh wait
submarines submarines have unique access
to these cables so it's the early 1970s
and American intelligence agencies team
up with the Navy to have them scour the
ocean floor looking for Russian
communication cables with the idea that
they could tap into the cables and
listen to them and lo and behold they
found one 120 meters below the surface
over in this eastern part of Russia they
found a cable that connected two Soviet
Naval bases and they put a literal tape
recorder into the cable and now they are
literally listening to Soviets talking
to each other about all sorts of
military things
none of it is encrypted in any way way
because no one expected them to dive
down and find this cable oh and they
were really clever they sort of only
Loosely attached it to the cable in case
they like needed to pull up the cable
for maintenance or something the little
device would fall off and no one would
ever know that they were being spied on
but the tapes that were recording like
filled up so divers had to go down and
retrieve the recording device and take
out the tapes and put in new tapes and
they did that like every month and they
were like we will never get caught for
this but then eventually they did it
turns out that an NSA employee got paid
35 000 from the Soviets to tell them
about this operation anyway that that
would be an amazing movie someone please
make that spy movie the fact is that
Subs still do a lot of spying they will
often have Navy Seals aboard that are
ready to dive and do dot dot dot
redacted we have no idea like we have
literally no idea what they do for
obvious reasons there is evidence that
the US and UK spy agencies still tap
into cables like the undersea fiber
optic cables that like govern the
internet at and that they do this all
the time see Edward snowden's big leak
and some deep dive into that I'm not
going to go into it but we know that
submarines spy we know that countries
are always spying on each other this
should not be surprising in fact during
the research for this video I felt the
insatiable desire to dive down the
rabbit hole of how submarines spy and I
didn't because I'm trying to stay
disciplined and I'm trying to tell this
story but leave a comment if you want me
to make that video and I will consider
it because there is a lot more about
that topic let's move on
[Music]
okay so let's get up to speed where are
we today with submarines according to
the U.S Navy's website the U.S has 71
submarines 53 of them are fast attack
subs and 14 are the ballistic missile
Subs that sit there and be our deterrent
and four are guided missile Subs but
then there's other sources that say that
there's only 68 submarines I don't know
all of this is like classified and we're
not supposed to know and no one's
supposed to know but we know a lot but
not specifics and like I mentioned all
of these Subs have very different
capabilities fast attack subs for
example are optimized for closer attacks
they use a lot of cruise missiles which
are launched through these big tubes and
have jet engines and computer brains for
navigation they're way more precise but
they can still go pretty far I mean
we're talking like 2 400 kilometers away
800 kilometers an hour like they're
still very very effective long-term
weapons Russia says it launched 26 crew
missiles today 59 Tomahawk cruise
missiles have hit a Syrian Air Base
launching dozens of missiles targeting
the Syrian regimes but again the one
that like represents the mind-blowing
reality of what we humans have invented
is this sucker the Ohio class submarine
they do have Torpedoes and several other
sort of smaller scale weapons but it's
these tubes that are carrying missiles
which are carrying Warheads that are the
big defining Game Changer of this
technology so let me just break down the
Journey of these Rockets they can hit
targets that are upwards of 6 400
kilometers away it's like wider than the
entire United States and probably a lot
longer but of course the Navy won't tell
us these things because it's all
classified and they don't just carry
like one nuclear warhead they can carry
multiple and they're not all just going
to one place they actually get dropped
at different locations how an
unbelievable amount of scientific
Ingenuity let me explain it starts at
the Boost phase where the missile gets
its initial umph gets pushed out of the
water up into the air goes up into the
sky gets a bunch of momentum and then
the engine's cut and the missile just
has momentum and it starts to fly just
using the laws of physics it's literally
at the edge of space we're now in the
mid-course phase the missile then just
starts casually looking at the stars to
calibrate its position and then making
little micro adjustments to make sure
that it is perfectly on course for its
Target and this is where we need to talk
about Warheads no not not those these
little cones that aren't that little are
Warheads the most powerful weapons
humans have ever created these missiles
can have up to 12 of these cone-shaped
Warheads they're just hanging out on the
front tip of this rocket eventually this
missile reaches its highest point and
starts to come down at this phase the
missile starts spitting out the WarHeads
just at the right time just at the right
velocity and as they re-enter Earth's
atmosphere they start hurtling towards
their targets as far as 1500 kilometers
apart so like roughly the distance
between Iceland and Norway and then when
they get where they were programmed to
go I mean you know what happens
oh but that happens potentially 12 times
from this one rocket each one of these
explosions being roughly six times more
powerful than the bombs dropped on Japan
at the end of World War II okay so that
was one missile this submarine can hold
24 missiles like what have we created
luckily since World War II no one has
had to use nuclear weapons in any
conflict we've had a lot of threats
lately but luckily they just remain a
deterrent force and not an actual thing
that we use hopefully it stays that way
and yes several countries have the
ability to load these things onto their
floating weapons called submarines that
are lurking in the depths of the ocean
at all times spying and just sitting
there
okay so that's submarines well no that's
like a teaspoon of submarines this topic
could go on forever I mean seriously I
was this was a painful story to do
because there was so much I had to leave
on the table I have a feeling that I'm
gonna be making a few more videos about
submarines soon but let's just remember
what we've learned here we humans have
invented something pretty wild something
that should be impossible the ability
for a bunch of us to live underwater in
these floating buildings for months at a
time we load these things up with enough
Firepower to turn entire countries to
dust all in the name of never having to
use them that is the Paradox of modern
conflict and yet the thing I'm taking
away from having spent a lot of time
thinking about submarines is that humans
can kind of do whatever they put their
minds to making power out of nuclear
fission and putting that into an
underwater weapon like what shooting
Rockets into space having them look at
the stars and then land wherever they
want to humans did this we did it
because of fear and skepticism and
conflict we did this to get ahead to be
more powerful but we did this and that
in some weird way gives me hope that
someday when the best Minds aren't
directed to the priorities of power and
conflict we humans will continue to make
magic happen magic that helps more and
more people live better lives making
impossible things possible
[Music]
thank you for watching my video on
submarines what you're not looking at
right now is all the props we have that
were just sort of like in the background
blurred out but they're super cool look
at this this model of the USS West
Virginia you can see the little silos up
here
for the nukes all these guys
what I didn't tell you is that my
father-in-law is actually the captain of
a submarine one of the ssbns so I had
some major Insider info that I've been
learning about for literally a decade
and that helped spur this video on I am
getting more and more excited about the
community we're building Over The
Newsroom The Newsroom is what we call
our patreon it just sounds way cooler to
call The Newsroom we have a community of
people that we ask for feedback on
things for advice on things we have live
streams I just did a live stream with
the community it was really cool you
also get an extra video every month it's
a behind the scenes Vlog of how we make
what we make here in the studio you meet
the people the team you see the
processes you see the shenanigans it's a
good time and you also get the fuzzy
feeling that you are supporting
independent journalism here on YouTube
so go check that out patreon.com Johnny
Harris we have Luts and presets which
help you color your videos and photos we
have a lot more videos if you're new
around here uh subscribe to the channel
because we publish publish a lot lately
like as the team has grown we just
published tons of videos now which is
fun and
and we have that's all we have I've
reached the end of what we have to give
to you and now I am done telling you
what I can give to you what can you give
to me okay bye thank you everyone
[Music]